this could seriously [ __ ] up a prison
it's already in the prisons I managed to
dodge it in the UK I did a talk down
view shook hands with the prisoners and
the guards and everything and that was
the first prison to get it in this
country the whole - that was there just
about a week before so in Iran they
released prisoners in Iran because they
thought they would have a better chance
of survival in Italy the prisoners have
been rioting and people have been
murdered
there are prison escapes going on right
now because think about it like I said
the people at the bottom of society
social pyramid they're gonna die the
most they know this if this oxygen
required and breathing apparatus
required I forgot to give all that to
the prisoners to save their lives no way
hell no yeah they're gonna give it to
the people who are law-abiding citizens
the ones that they can the ones that
aren't getting turned the way that is so
prisoners know they're gonna die so this
escapes and there's all there's all
kinds of chaos in the prison's all over
the world right now just and it's just I
think there's gonna be a lot more riots
and people escaping and people kicking
off into prisons and then there's the
prison staff you know they're considered
essential workers they've got to keep
the prison population fed and everything
else right so I've watched some of the
testimony since then they're complaining
you know they're gonna be a hugely
at-risk thing it will spread like
wildfire through the prison's oh my god
yeah prisons people there is such close
quarters they're in line to get food at
the cafeteria I mean it's it just seems
like a death pit people are war house
for profits in the prisons like battery
chickens and hens and they're the you
know ideal circumstances for the virus
to thrive and you know when I was in
there there was like outbreaks of Mercer
and people with sores on people and you
know all the time all the tattooing and
intravenous drug use
so yeah this it's it's conducive to
absolutely fire ignited in the prisons
or more than nature resets everything
periodically because that hasn't
happened in our lifetimes we are not
adjusted to it and we didn't expect it
and it's a shock to our system but if
you read the history books books like
Guns Germs and Steel and other books
that I've got histories of pandemics
you'll see this is just par for the
course from nature
[Music]
[Laughter]